we may have real ufo footage whoa
what we have deduced it is not a visual
effect it's not some sort of in-camera
trick this is something that was
actually captured by a camera and we
don't know what it is let's become real
let's freaking sherlock holmes oh wait
sam just found something
i received a video that is unexplainable
i brought everybody into this room
because it's very very important they
all see this we may have real ufo
footage this is a big deal this is a
huge deal for this debunking show
[Laughter]
no this is this is the new me
it's important that everybody sees this
because i'm going to need all the brains
i can find to figure out this video
[Music]
a lot of shooting stars
yeah wow
a lot of shooting stars so those are
just airplanes
okay
airplanes and satellites fairfare i'm
guessing then you guys saw the ufo
[Music]
i sent an email two months ago from a
man named jordan who he has a website
lostsasquatch.com he makes custom knives
things like that he's an outdoorsman and
this guy says hey
i have something i cannot explain i've
shown it to everybody and they can't
explain it can you take a look maybe you
guys can debunk it on your show he took
a time lapse while he was camping this
is about a five hour time lapse i have
the exact gps coordinates the date and
the time and there's something in this
time lapse footage which i am not able
to explain
you see it yeah no what oh
there it is whoa
what
it's like a little orb of dark matter so
the first time i watched this there was
a lot of compression and who knows what
compression is doing to an image so i
reached out to jordan to get the actual
raw files from the camera he actually
took all of his raw.cr2 files i mean
it's raw sensor data that's coming off
is like ones and zeros and hasn't been
turned into an image yet and he put them
up online all like eight gigs of them
and he sent them to me so what we're
watching right now is an image sequence
from the actual raw files from jordan's
camera
this is the sort of ufo sighting that is
incredibly easy to do with visual
effects you can literally just pick any
random star crop it out and animate it
it's like this is a very very doable vfx
shot to fake
the key difference this is verifiably
the raw data coming off of a memory card
rather than something that is
manipulated on a computer and made to
look like it's raw data exactly all the
other videos we've watched have been on
youtube they've been you know compressed
befores but this is a situation where
because we have the raw files we know
that they have not been manipulated we
are looking at truly the raw files this
is a real ufo yeah unidentified flying
object yep because we have deduced it is
not a visual effect it's not some sort
of in-camera trick this is something
that was actually captured by a camera
and we don't know what it is it's a real
ufo
it's a real
alien
[Laughter]
question
you said this guy's name was sasquatch
something
so
yeah
does this kind of undermine the
credibility if someone's like a
sasquatch hunter you know
it's lost sasquatch he makes custom
damascus knives okay
it's a good question it's a fair
question
it's not sasquatchhunters.com
so the interesting thing about this
footage is that it's a time lapse it
rules out a lot of things that normal
footage would have because time lapse
you now have something that's going to
be in the sky here for five hours
meaning it can't be a helicopter why
can't it not be a helicopter helicopters
i don't believe have the fuel to stay in
the air for five hours straight wouldn't
you also see a helicopter and hear a
helicopter and wouldn't it also have to
be super high up to be that small though
in the frame yeah you know it had to be
really high up and you have blinking
lights i mean once again it's a time
lapse but you probably at least in front
of the frame see a red or green and we
can rule out that it's a drone because
it's way too way too small it's in the
air for five straight hours there are
not any drones that have a five hour
flight time for the batteries dude what
if it's literally just like a little ant
inside the camera on the sensor
but it goes behind the clouds it does it
goes behind the clouds this would be so
much easier to ride off if it didn't go
behind the clouds
that is so weird wait so that
it's not a satellite though so what do
we know about satellites they move in a
in an elliptical they're just going at
17 and a half thousand miles an hour in
whatever direction they want it can be
this way it could be that way it could
be this way but it's all consistent but
it's consistent yeah yes yes maybe it's
just a satellite on its commute to its
position you know
they they got to get there somehow no no
that's not what a
rocket launcher looks like
any spacecraft coming from earth they
would not move like that you know you
might get to a spot and change orbit but
your base is going to be in a circle or
an elliptical orbit around you know the
planet and if you change your path it's
just going to change that curve a little
bit and like throw out part of like the
loop of that elliptical in different
ways there's no
zigzags
it literally looks like the like someone
dragging a cursor like that kind of path
it does i think it's a piece of
experimental
aircraft technology human or alien
[Laughter]
okay hold up hold up stop the video
right here because there's a couple
things that i need to point out to you
right now i think personally this entire
clip was created by today's sponsor
squarespace now let me tell you what i
see first and foremost they say that
this clip is five hours long now i might
be crazy but with squarespace's
beautiful award-winning templates in
five hours there's a heck of a lot you
could do to build your own website using
those templates now remember they're
award-winning too you know what else is
award-winning they're 24 7 customer
service just another thing to keep in
mind but look let's get back to the
footage okay let's focus on the facts
zigzagging star pattern what this star
does is almost the same thing as
squarespace's multiple contributors
tools
you can go around the different people
in the office allowing each one of those
people to contribute something different
to the website and that's not all very
importantly squarespace also has what's
called a traffic overviews tool and
those analytics are going to be able to
tell you how people are coming into your
website what pages they like the most
and then you as the creator of that site
can tailor your website to the people
that are coming to it and make it more
efficient for your business or service
or product it's clear the footage speaks
for itself
last thing they're missing okay if you
want to get 10 off a website or domain
for yourself and you wanted to get
started creating your own website today
you could go to squarespace.com corridor
crew and you could get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain it's
written in the stars
it's written in the stars just click the
link in the description below anyways um
uh that's it i gotta get back to the uh
to the um
to the video
okay all right until next time
so all we know for sure is that it's
behind the clouds and it's emitting a
little bit of light and it's in the air
for five hours that's the weird part
which is like what is what is here in
the air for five hours so another thing
we know it's behind the clouds so that
means it has to be at least as high as
the clouds what's like the altitude of
clouds let's look up cloud heights uh
what kind of clouds are these are these
cumulonimbus
those look like altocumulus clouds
potentially
i'm thinking those are also cumulus
clouds maybe straight no they're not
strong cumulus could be serostratus not
too too thick they might be altostratus
but yeah there's some form of stratus
clouds they're also stratus are also
cumulus wait wait no they could be
cirrus clouds but either way if they're
altostratus or alto cumulus that's six
thousand five hundred to twenty thousand
feet and cirrus clouds are to above
twenty thousand feet oh boy so either
way whatever it is it's way up in the
clouds it could be a balloon that's what
i was gonna say i mean balloons could go
very high go extremely high into the
into the atmosphere maybe it's david
blaine's ascension too
i think it might be a balloon that has
you know propellers on it so is this
something like this
is this is this what we were thinking
you could see a blimp flying like that
except for the fact that it's really
high up it's tiny
maybe it is a drone balloon
if you think about it something like
that isn't very hard you just fill a big
balloon with a bunch of helium you put a
bunch of propellers on it and a little
control module that is you know
controlled by gps autonomous
what is something like this
twin balloon airship hits high frontier
that's 30 feet long with six foot long
propellers
and then they can get up to 20 miles in
the air so this is the scale of
technology we're talking about like that
that kind of that can maybe be one
business look
i have the exact date in the exact time
in the exact location so i'm thinking
that if we can figure out what direction
the camera's pointing this will help us
figure out what we're actually looking
at let's become real let's freaking
sherlock holmes i'm pulling up sky guide
right now i'm i'm getting our exact
direction that we're looking nailed down
here oh there's that's jupiter
and that's saturn yeah so those bright
stars are jupiter and saturn boom boom
boom boom yep bing bing bing bing bing
bing bing bing bing bing right there so
we are looking we're looking south
southeast right now you know it's
southeast of uh
lake powell what
very very area 51 351 is southeast of
lake powell no you're kidding what no
i'm not kidding
we are looking at the sky above area 51.
oh wait i lied i lied
all right
all right all right so what we do know
is that based on the stars looking kind
of like southwest if we can pull up
historical flight data or try to find
any information on some sort of like
experimental balloon aircraft launch
that would seal the deal
is it possible pull up flight
information do they have like like just
google area51.com and like check out
which uh flights left
i believe you can pull up flight data
though oh
my my
my
oh wait sam just found something in the
table below you'll find records of
stratospheric balloons launched from
different countries and places during
2020. there's a city in nevada called
winnemucca in 2020 they're launching
balloons practically three times a day
for all of june
big big balloons that had flight
durations as long as 330 days
oh boy and these are very large large
scale like
stratosphere level balloons that are
very very large i think it's a balloon
i'm just saying people are like oh
weather balloons it's always a weather
balloon it's not like a rare one-off
occurrence to see a balloon it's like
they're
all over the place what's the what's the
name of the company that's doing those
balloon launches
project loon
what is project road
i need to figure out the secrets of
project loom
[Laughter]
wait project loon began his research and
development project by
x
oh oh these are for uh internet yeah
these are internet balloons
is a google attempt to put internet uh
to rural areas using balloons that can
stay in there for 300 days and of course
google canned it a few months ago yeah
if you have any more secrets on project
loon
let us know
the balloons are maneuvered by adjusting
their altitude in the stratosphere to
float to a wind layer after identifying
the wind layer with the desired speed
and direction using wind data so i think
we kind of saw that there could be going
up through different wind layers
oh it's like a maze
so we saw it going up there at the end
we saw it kind of like hover in a spot
and it's like okay now it's actually
going to get to a different layer so it
goes up a bit and kind of moves over and
then it's like oh we got to get to that
other layer so it really goes up
shifting
shifting currents here's another thing
the company states the particular
altitude and layer of the stratosphere
is advantageous for the balloons because
it's low wind speeds which are usually
recorded between five to twenty miles
per hour which is about as fast as that
balloon was probably moving in the shot
that's slow it's also an area of minimal
turbulence
guys i've pulled up a balloon flight
path demonstrating a flight path that
matches
whoa dude it's very inconsistent that's
weird okay we figured it out oh it looks
just like the flight path
it looks just like the flight path i
think we cracked it
this this is a project loon balloon this
is a project this could be a project
loon balloon i think this is a project
loom balloon so this is just some google
experiment i may be overconfident here
but to me i've heard enough to drop the
u from ufo this is an fo to me
we did it guys we did it you know what
we finally did it people have alternate
theories please
we'd love to read them in the comments
below
and if you can pinpoint this exact
balloon flight path or whatever it might
be
great also please leave a comment below
and if there's not then we're right back
to square one it could be aliens
it could be an alien balloon